the right to family I've seen Abel I'm
looking at it now I learned I what is it
like playing a character that has been
previously played by a different actor
do you take a lot of their essence or do
you just go to a new person new rules a
little bit i dead new person who knows a
little bit but only because we've gone
back in time in the 60s so it was kind
of important to show a different time
they ever change otherwise why do I
started off because I thought well
should I study sort of Ian McKellen and
then I was talking to Matthew Vaughn he
was like no you know what your accents
kind of strange and weird so I like it
let's keep with that and I said okay so
we did that in first class and then he
and McKellen was in the second film with
me so rather than him ask him to do my
accent I sort of then tried to do a
little bit of his so it's kind of ended
up sort of yeah hybrid was it like
looking in a mirror with these
prestigious actors is it kind of like
yes this is what I'm gonna grow up to be
like so Ian McKellen
did you look wistfully his knighthood
that's political selling Dark Phoenix
would you I get a scene with Patrick
where we got Josh they look at each
other in the eye and go nose-to-nose and
that was got a real up-close thing he's
a very different actor for me in a very
different person but you look if I had
to choose somebody it'd be like then
that'd be a nice one
are you sick of shaving your head by the
way no I like it yeah oh thanks very
much so I've been told
I enjoy it it's low maintenance and
surprisingly doesn't displease me when I
look in the middle also easier to put
the helmet on no hat hair he doesn't owe
you a mirror though that's never been
comfortable no Patrick says that has
cerebral his helmet was way more
comfortable than my helmet I don't know
if minds are just larger and heavier but
mine's really had a reg on it the dog in
real bad plus I got an a blow electric
shocks
I know collectively shot a few times Jim
that method acting they're hooked me up
no plug it in plug it in are you scared
little girl answers to a man in a chair
are you the most powerful creature on
the planet did you lean into anyone
else's superhero experience as an
adopted as your own or were you just
fighting not let's go fresh oh I just
went in fresh I was like hey hey guys
what didn't even know for the last 20
years you know I was just kind of
hanging out and and I didn't show up as
the expert in special effects the expert
is it that with that that's what kind of
forever well I've been doing this the
whole time well that's okay because
maybe it means all forever he'll be in
black panther nice segue next question
if you could team up with anyone else in
the MCU who would it be and why oh
brother hammer brother hammer thought
anyone would go Thor I also wanna know
do you have favorites do you have other
characters in the x-men that you are a
huge fan of and you're like oh if I
could have a day acting in there the
problem is if you're a fan of them you
don't want to see anyone else play that
character it's so true but I really love
magneto so you want to play magneto no
but I love him
a girl died if you got your own movie
focusing on your character pitch me what
would it be about
I would love to do like a thing where
like me and Hallie team up and fight a
baddie like pass in future have to come
together otherwise that wouldn't make
sense you know I mean like we save the
world me and Hallie you see her in John
week three as well I haven't seen John
with Shree yet it just came out I have
to see it she's fabulous and everything
what's your side clips to your picture
dad getting together and you know dad
yeah you know me and magneto Starsky mr.
scheme much I would like starts be much
I would watch that yeah that'd be
awesome I would want handlebar mustaches
definitely yeah for sure yeah
Cyclops very um I think it would be as
you know he'd just be alone in a cabin
or be no dialogue for the entire film
and then all of a sudden like every
superhero movie there would be a big
battle at the revenant almost with
Cyclops what have you had your goggles
off just a whole movie like a matrix
maybe a mystery that's great the most
expensive movie pepper Oh what's a tough
love would you give you a character but
we'll also a flip side what do you love
the most about your character oh I like
the loyal team yeah yeah yeah character
that I play and then I don't know
sometimes he takes it a little too far
yeah to where it becomes a multi-bit
would you say Cyclops is in Pisces
because like you know I have to ask my
mom about that I don't know if it's a
he's a Scorpio Pisces rising and maybe
his moon is in Sagittarius for sure yeah
you can see it so what about with stole
me what do you love the most about her
and what does she need a little tough
love IVA uh I love storm and how like
silent strong she is but I would like
for her to allow herself to be a little
bit more opinion
you know I don't think she says it out
loud she just kind of like doesn't with
her eyes and I'm like just say it you
know just be real because I think that
she would also be sassy
I think storm would be so sad what's her
birth son storm storms of cancer 100%
Virgo rising humans in Gemini what do
you love most about Quicksilver and what
what tough love do you need to give him
well I like that he's really fast and
then tough love I think he needs to uh
really slow down look okay I think you
should talk to his dad I think yeah oh
did you bet hey I'm your son you're my
family James doc Phoenix is this
something that you like come on let's
bring it yes when I was a kid reading
comics and there was a kid that read a
lot of comics Dark Phoenix was my
favorite storyline in all the comics so
with my dream I wasn't even a dream to
actually make his movie and everyone
thought it'd be a movie but once I got
into making x-men movies it was my dream
to tell this story to tell it right
we told a version of it an x-men The
Last Stand but it was really a
background story in that and we didn't
really focus on Jean yeah and in this
one I really wanted to explore what
Chris Claremont and the original guys
who wrote and created Dark Phoenix in
the comics I wanted to explore this idea
of the most powerful person in the world
who can't control their power yeah
and that's what's exciting about x-men
is how powerful just to have riveting
scary relentless power yeah I mean that
was what was exciting to me was this
notion that in all of the x-men movies
you know they're very powerful
characters but this is the movie where
one of the x-men becomes more powerful
than anybody or anything else not just
on earth but in the galaxy and while
that would seem like a positive thing
when you can't control it so while the
destructive and negative thing and that
polarity of like the enjoying that
incredible burst of power but also being
terrified by it was always what was so
compelling to me about the Dark Phoenix
story and was trying to bring to screen
in this and so
is you know this amazing actress who has
incredible strength but also can play
incredible vulnerability and fragility
and the character needs to be able to
play both because she's kind of the hero
and the villain of this movie so yeah
what was fun to me was that after having
made a lot of x-men movies as a writer
and a producer and now I get to do as a
director to have the most powerful x-men
/ex woman we've ever had on screen what
was it like taking the late going into
directing um you know I've always wanted
to direct and I will say that it was a
really natural organic transition as a
writer producer on these movies I've
done a lot of directorial type work I
work closely with the actors I've become
very close with these actors I've
studied filmmakers having been on the
sets of not just these films but the
film work worked at Ridley Scott can
brought on a couple films Jim mangled
some of the great filmmakers of our time
and so I really started them and watched
them and with these x-men movies I've
really been inside the process so the
transition because I felt so supported
by this cast and it was the cast that
really at the end of Apocalypse came to
me and said they really wanted me to
direct the next movie Jen Lauren
specifically it was I will give her
credit and/or blame for really forcing
me to take the leap she said I'm not
coming back did you know that was x-men
movies unless you direct it and so I
said okay well that's that's a good deal
what's that like because obviously like
we've grown up with Jennifer Lawrence
being mystique / Raven what does that
like sort of like closing that chapter
part of what's so fascinating about
having worked with Jennifer on these
x-men movies is that you know when we
cast Jennifer in x-men first class she
was a completely unknown child I mean
she was 17 years old or something like
that and I've and have tried as the
writer to bring that kind of complexity
and evolution and sophistication to the
character as well and and have the
character play all of the sort of
emotional range that I know Jennifer is
capable of and another Jennifer
experiences in in real life as well and
and so in this movie you know this movie
in many ways when I conceived it from
the beginning it was sort of the
culmination of all of these x-men movies
and certainly this cycle of x-men movies
for this family that started to
strangers and came together as a family
and they're sort of torn apart in this
film and so I felt as though you know
without giving too much away that Jen's
character needed to be part of that real
culmination at the center of that
combination because mystique is central
to so many characters I mean she's
probably she's not ever been the hero or
the protagonist of any movies but she's
so pivotal in these movies because she
his relationship with magneto with beast
with Xavier with the x-men themselves
she really is the center of so many the
fulcrum of so many relationships so I
wanted to really explore that in this
film
[Music]